(audience applauds)
- Welcome back!
The first time I heard this
next guest sing on The Voice,
I turned my chair around immediately.
Of course, so did John, Gwen, and Shelton
because she is incredible.
She was an overwhelming fan
favorite for very good reason.
Performing "Christmas in Chicago,"
let's hear it for Katie Kadan.
(audience applauds)
(bright music)
♪ Christmas in Chicago ♪
♪ Music everywhere ♪
♪ Everywhere ♪
♪ Snow falling from heaven ♪
♪ Magic in the air ♪
♪ All of us together ♪
♪ Together ♪
♪ Sleigh bells ringing
through the streets ♪
♪ Through the streets ♪
♪ Christmas in Chicago ♪
♪ It's home, home to me ♪
♪ Chicago ♪
♪ Bells are ringing, the city is singing ♪
♪ Weather's getting cold outside ♪
♪ We'll light up some lights
on the downtown tree ♪
♪ And we'll be chilling
at Kringle's tonight ♪
♪ Build a fire, put some old records on ♪
♪ Pour a glass of champagne or two ♪
♪ I'll raise my glass to you ♪
♪ Christmas in Chicago ♪
♪ Music everywhere ♪
♪ Everywhere ♪
♪ Snow falling from heaven ♪
♪ Heaven ♪
♪ Magic in the air ♪
♪ All of us together ♪
♪ Together ♪
♪ Sleigh bells ringing
through the streets ♪
♪ Through the streets ♪
♪ Christmas in Chicago ♪
♪ Is home, home to me ♪
♪ Chicago ♪
♪ Warm flannel sheets,
lunches in the streets ♪
♪ A Midwest memory's made, all right ♪
♪ Just a few short
hours and I'll be home ♪
♪ And I will wrap you in my arms ♪
♪ And you can hold me tight ♪
♪ Hold me tight ♪
♪ Christmas in Chicago ♪
♪ Music everywhere ♪
♪ Everywhere ♪
♪ Snow falling from heaven ♪
♪ Heaven ♪
♪ Magic in the air ♪
♪ All of us together ♪
♪ Together ♪
♪ Sleigh bells ringing
through the streets ♪
♪ Through the streets ♪
♪ Christmas in Chicago ♪
♪ Is home, home to me ♪
♪ Home sweet home ♪
♪ Christmas in Chicago ♪
(audience applauds)
Merry Christmas, Kelly!
(audience cheers)
- All right, y'all!
Katie's new holiday song,
"Christmas in Chicago" is
available now to download
and stream wherever you listen to music.